Israeli forces have detained two
relatives of the suspected Palestinian
gunmen The Raid took place in the
village of nilene in the occupied West
Bank let's get more with Nita Ibrahim
who joins us from Ramallah so I need a
raid in nilene in the occupied West Bank
following that shooting in Tel Aviv tell
us what happened
people there told us that the Israeli
forces have stayed there for six hours
where confrontations erupted between
Palestinians and Nadine and the Israeli
forces we know that they've detained the
father and the brother of the shooter as
well as taking measurements of the house
in preparation for a house demolition
what happens in these cases that usually
when there are Israelis were killed it's
becoming a standard Israeli procedure to
demolish the home of the shooters now in
this case we don't have any uh killed
people in the shooting in Tel Aviv yet
but the usually this is the standard
practice by the Israeli forces now also
there was another incident elsewhere in
the occupied West Bank where a
Palestinian a 21 year old was killed by
Israeli forces Sorry by an Israeli
settler he was near an illegal Israeli
settlement Outpost and according to
Witnesses they say if they don't know
what happened because the Israeli
narrative is that he had weapons and or
at least knives and he tried to attack
the Israel and Israeli settler but we
don't have a Palestinian narrative to
counter that that's hard to know what
happened but it's uh it's worth
mentioning that the Israeli weights have
been intensifying in the occupied West
Bank the house demolitions as well the
killings were talking about 78
Palestinians who were killed by Israeli
forces since the beginning of the year
and we're only in the in March indeed
Anita thank you for that Nita Ibrahim
live for us in Ramallah